Let's clean my nasty cast iron pan.
This has been sitting out since last night's dinner
and the food is very dried out and crusty.
And it's time to get it nice and shiny again.
I will start with some hot running water.
This is gonna soften up the food and make it easier to wash off.
To clean the pans, I like to use this lodge scrubber.
It's chain mail with a silicone something in the middle
which doesn't retain any bacteria so it never smells.
And I can just throw it in the dishwasher.
And I think it's getting kinda grubby.
I'm gonna rinse out the pan several times to get any loose food off.
And turn the temperature down
because it's way too hot for my hands right now.
Then I wanna get to scrub in this part.
It's just obvious.
You just scrub,
scrub, scrub,
scrub the dirty food off.
There's no way around this.
It's a dirty pan,
it needs to be cleaned.
I'll then go for a few rounds of rinsing.
I'm gonna try and rinse off any loose food
and make sure any spot that I miss,
I'm gonna continue to go back over.
This process only takes about 30 seconds.
It's really not long. And the scrubber chainmail thing does a great job.
I'm gonna rinse the back
cause I don't wanna have any food stuck to the back or extra grease
cause then that creates a carbon buildup.
If you keep Light in the bottom
and food builds up on it and it just gets nasty.
Then we're gonna head over to the stove and get this dry.
This pan needs to be completely bone dry
before we can put any oil on her.
So I'm gonna make a heat and use a paper towel to dry.
Then I'm gonna coat her with some avocado oil.
I use this instead of olive oil because it doesn't smoke as much.
Um, olive oil smokes at a lower heat point than avocado oil.
I've used coconut oil in the past, and if I have coconut oil,
I will use that,
but my favourite is avocado oil.
I'm gonna let her sit here and get real hot.
Then when she's colder,
she's gonna hang out with the rest of her friends.